then he went Donald Trump you know  Donald Trump I love Donald Trump but no  more dropped by the drop boxes are just  so bad no more drop boxes Dickinson  hologic and cephe cephahide  they sacrifice every day for the  furniture and future that was about a  guy named a rhino named Mitt Romney Mitt  Romney real Beauty had to give the  American people their voice back by  building something called truth truth  essential  he voted against Kate's law and he voted  for  Obama  amnesty this is the very definition of  totalitarianism you know we've endorsed  Dr Oz we've endorsed  JP right J.D Mandel and he's doing great  I've had more investigations and Jesse  James Billy the could